bonjour et merci de répondre aux
questions sur rt france vous l'avez donc
communiquer sur vos réseaux sociaux il
ya quelques heures l'agrément a été
prorogée jusqu'au 2 avril
énième report comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à bien d'abord je remercie
tous ceux qui nous ont soutenus à cette
occasion car je pense qu'on était qu'on
allait vers un non renouvellement nous à
gaz sont un peu le pouvoir et celui ci
avait la tentation de ne pas renouveler
cet agrément
donc il ya eu des soutiens très divers
notamment sur le réseaux sociaux mais
aussi les partis politiques de tous
bords et donc cette instruction est
reportée jusqu'au 2 avril
je pense que c'est une instruction qui
est très politique que le report
jusqu'au 2 avril est aussi une décision
très politique parce que manifestement
les questions qu'on va nous poser sont
des questions qui étaient déjà connus la
direction des affaires criminelles qui
est en charge du dossier
justement je me permets de citer votre
présidente élise van beneden interrogé
hier chez nos confrères de france info
je cite c'est jean castex qui va prendre
la décision puisqu'on a porté plainte
contre eric dupond moretti
donc le garde des sceaux avec cette
nouvelle prolongation vous voyez un lien
de cause à effet est ce que cela
sous-entend qu'anticor dérange peut-être
est-ce que vous étiez en train de dire
oui et le grand paradoxe c'est que le
renouvellement de l'agrément c'est une
décision qui appartient au gouvernement
alors que un certain nombre de membres
du gouvernement ou de proches du pouvoir
sont concernés par nos actions donc jean
castex va vraiment devoir faire preuve
d'une loyauté républicaine pour
renouveler cet agrément et je pense
qu'il ya des tensions qu'il ya des
appels pour ne pas ne pas le renouveler
et encore une fois je gm à sion de qui
ben je pense que de diverses personnes
qui sont dérangés par nos actions ou qui
pourraient être dérangé par nos actions
car nous avons effectivement un certain
nombre de proches du pouvoir mais nous
avons aussi
sur l'ensemble du territoire nationale à
portefeuille d'actions il ya des
lanceurs dallaire qui nous concerne qui
nous concerne qui est qu'ils signalent
des fins et tout ceci gêne un peu et
donc alors en même temps c'est normal
que les citoyens contrôlent le pouvoir
ce qui est paradoxal c'est que je n'ai
pas d'actions citoyennes en france et
désagréments pour trois associations et
peu pour avoir cet agrément il faut
encore demandé au pouvoir s'il veut bien
être loyal et entériné un dossier dès
lors que ce dossier a fait l'objet d'une
instruction très méticuleuse vous avez
dit que vous attendiez à ce que la la
prorogation l'agrément ne soit pas
renouvelée c'était 10 d'ici lundi
à quelle réponse est ce que vous
attendez du coup le 2 avril si
l'agrément ne devait pas être être
renouvelé à quoi est-ce que vous vous
attendriez
que deviendra anticorps comment est ce
que vous allez continuer à agir d'abord
c'est un c'est quelque chose d'important
que l'agrément parce que ça conditionne
la possibilité de surmonter l'inertie du
parquet donc le parquet est trop prudent
quand des affaires sont classés et bien
cet anticorps qui peut intervenir
nous sommes intervenus dans une affaire
concernant richard ferrand nous sommes
intervenus dans une affaire concernant
koller qui est un personnage important
de l'elysée sont des affaires qui ont
été classés et donc effectivement ça
nous l'aurons plus si l'agrément n'est
pas ses possibilités nous leurrons plus
si l'agrément n'est pas renouvelé en
revanche subsistent en tant
qu'association et nous agirons devant le
juge administratif
évidemment la mesure devant le juge
administratif est une action longour et
ça durera plusieurs mois peut-être même
une année et est ce que le 2 avril
il est encore possible qu'il y ait un
nouveau report n'y a pas de règles ou
des lignes concernées convocation le
décret prévoit quatre mois plus deux
mois au maximum
donc le 2 avril ce sera une décision de
refus implicite qui pourraient être
attaquées dernière question au sujet de
la corruption comment se situe la france
par rapport aux autres pays dans le
monde la france se situe à un rang très
médiocre transparancy international a
fait un recensement des perceptions de
la corruption la français est au milieu
d'eux des pays de l'union européenne et
vous savez aussi que des économistes a
déclassé la france et la france est
aujourd'hui un pays qui est une
démocratie défaillante souhaiterions
qu'il n'y ait pas un indicateur
supplémentaire de cette défaillance
démocratique
rendez-vous le 2 avr merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions eric alt je
rappelle que vous êtes donc le vit
président de l'association anticor vous
êtes également magistrat